Disney Princesses have got it all and
we're not just talking about royal
titles and amazing singing voices their
sweet sassy and always ready for an
adventure with their favorite animal
sidekick in tow they're unstoppable
always have a plan and can beat their
enemies with a frying pan like it's
nobody's business we might think we know
everything about Disney Princesses but
unlike their stories they're far from
being open books we've got 20
interesting facts coming your way keep
watching to find out which Disney
Princess almost received a turkey as a
sidekick I'm guessing you don't have
much experience with heat nope youngest
princess have you ever wondered who the
youngest Disney Princesses if you
guessed Snow White you're right she's
listed as the youngest Disney Princess
at just 14 years old
Lefty's any lefties in the house well
you're in good company there are two
left-handed Disney princesses in the
Magic Kingdom Mulan and tiana are both
left-handed Mulan controls her bow and
arrow with her left hand and Tiana
shares this trait with the actress who
voices her anika Noni Rose wow hey you
got the makings of a decent mushroom
encik oh you think so American accents
dizzy princesses are from all over the
world
yep they all speak with an American
accent please strange right in fact
there is only one princess who doesn't
speak with an American accent can you
guess who it is if you guessed Merida
from brave you're correct
Ariel's cousin and Hercules are first
cousins that's right they technically
share the same grandfather King Triton
is Hercules uncle and Souza's Ariel's
uncle - pretty cool right
Cinderella shoe size ever wonder just
how small Cinderella's feet are we know
she has the smallest feet in the kingdom
but just how small are those dainty
little feet according to our sources her
shoe size is four and a half
that's one tiny glass slipper duet with
a villain did you know that there is
only one Disney princess who has a duet
with a villain can you guess who it is
well we'll give you a hint the villain
in question comes from the Southern
Isles that's right onna
it's the only princess to sing with a
villain the despicable Prince Hans pants
please
true fans know everything about Disney
Princess fashion but let's see if you
know that you are the only two Disney
Princesses who wear pants instead of a
dress if you said Mulan and jasmine
you're right top star princess Disney
Princesses are known for their beautiful
singing voices but one princess in
particular was almost voiced by a super
famous pop star Princess Tiana almost
had Beyonce's vocals coming out of her
little frog mouth colors of the ice have
you ever noticed how Elsa's ice palace
would change colors and frozen that's
because the ice color changes to reflect
this princesses emotions that's right
it's blue when she's happy yellow when
she feels angry red when she's scared
and purple when she's feeling sad
recycled animation if you watch the
dance scene between Belle and the bees
you might notice something familiar
apparently the animators recycled the
animation from Aurora's dance with the
prince in Sleeping Beauty looks like the
animators were a little short on time
talking Turkey can you imagine what it
would have been like if Pocahontas soos
sidekick was a talking turkey named red
feather well that's almost how it went
down
John Candy was set to voice the
character of the turkey ultimately
Disney went with Miko instead the
long-haired trend move over Rapunzel
you've got some competition in the
long-haired Department according to
Merida's fansite her hair would be 4
feet long if she straightened her curls
still Rapunzel's got married a beep her
hair is 70 feet long Wow tatted up can
you figure out which Disney Princess is
the only one to have a tattoo we'll give
you a hint she probably asked for it to
be all the colors of the wind
if you're thinking Pocahontas you're
absolutely right
dimples free days there's only one
Disney princess out of all of them who
has dimples
not only does princess tiana have
gorgeous dimples but she's also the only
princess to have a professional job of
course Cinderella worked hard but she
never saw a paycheck
seeing a villain we know that onna was
the only princess to sing a duet with a
villain but did you know there is only
one princess to ever kiss a villain
Princess Jasmine gave Jafar a big smooch
when she was trying to distract him from
Aladdin snowy kingdoms out of all the
princesses in the Magic Kingdom there
are only two who have ever encountered
snow before on an Elsa that would be
Belle and Mulan though Belle seemed to
have the most fun with it Olaf and Belle
would totally get along disgusting fairy
tale or fact there's only one Disney
Princess whose story is based off a real
person that person is Pocahontas the
rest of the princesses are made-up or
based on a legend like Mulan The Ballad
of Mulan
speaking of Mulan there's a famous
legend from China about a young woman
named Hua Mulan her story is told in the
Chinese folk song titled The Ballad of
Mulan however there's no actual proof
that she ever existed
archery while all of the disease
processes have many talents there are
only two who are trained in archery can
you guess who they are
if you guessed Mulan in Merida you would
be correct
Mulan had a bit of trouble at first but
she got the hang of it by the end of be
a man Walt's favorite have you ever
wondered who Walt Disney's favorite
princess was well we've got the answer
legend has it Cinderella was Walt's
favorite Disney Princess
in fact the scene where Cinderella's
dress transforms into a ballgown is his
favorite piece of animation ever do you
have a favorite Disney Princess if so
tell us in the comments thanks for
watching the things be sure to subscribe
to catch our latest Disney Princess
videos and click the thumbs up button if
you love Disney Princesses as much as we
do Tata for now
[Music]